la caída de un puente en Colombia el
miércoles dejó estas impactantes
imágenes Dos policías murieron y hubo
más de una decena de heridos hasta el
lugar se desplazó el jueves el ministro
de transportes Guillermo Reyes quien fue
prudente en su análisis de las causas
del derrumbe pero tampoco no puede salir
a hacer juicios de valor y a decir es
que el responsable es el concesionaria o
que el responsable fue un grupo al
margen de la ley o es que aquí hubo
choques entre dos vehículos no uno aquí
tiene que ser muy responsable más tarde
además en un comunicado el ministro dijo
que pronto habilitarían un puente
militar provisional cuando hablamos de
30 a 45 días no es un puente que se
pueda sustituir todo con estructura en
cemento estamos hablando de estructuras
tipo puentes militares que son los que
nos habilitan el paso y puentes que
sirvan además con carácter permanente el
puente la alambrada está en el suroeste
de Colombia separa los departamentos del
Quindío y el Valle del ca uca y cruza el
río de la vieja es un importante punto
de paso para la distribución de
mercancías porque por aquí pasa el 60%
de la carga Nacional del transporte
nacional hacia el interior del país y
viceversa saliendo por el puente de
Buenaventura las informaciones locales
reportan que el puente fue construido en
1984 su última inspección había sido
hace tan solo tres meses y no había
reportado preocupaciones ni de operación
ni capacidad